though it looks like other octopuses the  larger Pacific striped octopus seems to  break all the octopus rules first it  hunts its shrimp prey unlike any other  instead of pouncing on its victim it  starts by slowly stretching out its  dorsal arm sneaking up almost is it to  give it a hug after a tap on the  shoulder the surprise shrimp is quickly  consumed  also unusual for an octopus the larger  Pacific striped octopus is not  cannibalistic so when they mate the  male's of the species have no fear of  being eaten the mating pair grasp each  other's arms  sucker to sucker beak to beak once they  lay their eggs the females don't die  like most octopuses but are able to keep  mating and have more offspring despite  being known to scientists that study  them as the most antisocial animal alive  the larger Pacific striped octopus is  pretty warm and fuzzy for a cephalopod  you